which government institution like who
where where does the government get
things right
that's a tough one when it fails to
intervene
i i want to say something here if when
it comes to government like would this
be border patrols that are working for
the government is this who would be on
the board
so you need the border patrol that's a
government agency i'm not saying we you
heard me say i'm not about abolish
everything immediately i'm about create
institutions that are private and
community to give the support we need
then government institutions will either
get better i can't see how but they
might or they'll begin to go away
because other communities something
better correct something better will
step up but we have to create an
environment as long as government
monopolizes everything we're not able to
have community support and then that's
my issue if we set this is why i like
the the elvis island private idea
because eventually what will happen
immigration could be controlled by
privatized companies who know what
they're doing compete against each other
to make sure they do things right we
won't require a government eventually
they'll want to patrol their own they'll
begin to do this on their own if we
create the right environment the problem
i have is most people want a 30 second
10 second solution that's magical these
are systemic issues that will take 10
years to repair but we've got to set the
ball in motion that's the key government
is driven by a high time preference that
they have helped to create they have
helped through uh government schooling
to teach everyone that there's this
terrible thing that's happening because
we're letting you do this we're not
going to let you do any more we have a
magic fix that's going to fix it oops
that didn't fix it it made it worse we
need more control and it's an endless
cycle we saw this with kovid we've seen
this with terrorism we've seen it with
everything now the problem is
if you don't have something to replace
it with
then ultimately it's either this or
nothing now sometimes nothing's better
but there's something better than
nothing which is something that would
actually fix that problem perfect
example bitcoin cryptocurrency how much
easier is it us first to sell people on
ending central banking because there's
something already in place if there
wasn't we'd be and they said well what
are you going to replace the federal
reserve with well it's going to work out
the market will fix it that just saying
that to the average person you're
basically saying to them or what they
hear is i don't really care i care more
about my ideas than your well-being and
i'm super smart and i'm trying to tell
you that that's what the market will fix
this sounds like you have the market if
the market can fix this then let's use
the market to fix it which is why again
we need to focus more on okay
identifying the problem okay here's the
problem and here's how it was created or
made worse by government but then also
here is a solution that is outside of
government
so that government now to larry's point
can either compete with that or just not
do it anymore let's talk about what
government is for a second government is
at its core a monopoly that is enforced
with violence financed by theft
now whatever whether you think
government's necessary not necessary
whether you can whatever you consider
yourself let's just take a step back on
what government actually is
now let's ask this question if you were
going to come up with the best way to
provide a service would you settle on a
monopoly that is financed by uh theft
and enforced by is that where you'd like
to get your chicken sandwiches from is
that where you'd like to get your health
care from is that where you'd like to
get different things that you need from
a company that can do whatever it wants
to you and does not have to provide you
with any value and and the only reason
that you're even using them in the first
place is because you have no other
option and they will punish you if you
don't no
but we also can't say well we don't need
government we can just do it ourselves
we have to actually do it ourselves and
provide actual feasible solutions and
when possible with with borders not so
much you'd have to actually have
government policy to to bring in things
like the ellis island or whatever but
outside of that like for example
cryptocurrency the blockchain mutual aid
working together on the ground you can
actually come up with real feasible
solutions that work so that instead of
me having to have this long high-minded
philosophical first principles
discussion about how libertarianism is
going to work i can just say this that
fixed it
it's literally what i'm doing it's why
every time you ask me a question i said
i will give you a policy yeah i you may
not have liked my answer but i gave you
an answer every single time i didn't
fall back to ideology didn't fall back
to concepts i said we will do this every
single time that's why people are
following me because i give them actual
answers at the end of joe rogan's show
if anyone watches it by the way episode
1167 if anyone happens to just want to
watch it at the end of that episode he
said larry i love your ideas where'd
they come from i said well me and my
team we put them together we put
policies together he goes you better
lock those things down i said why he
said people will take them i said take
them i don't have to run then i can go
back to my business take the take it fix
the country fix my state i'll go home
i'll have to do this i got stuff to do i
got a family i got friends i'll go do
that instead so i'm about policy that's
what i'm all about if we have better
policies people to your point will just
go yeah that makes sense so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]